welcome back y'all today we honor the
legacy of Dr Martin Luther King Jr I am
here with Cedric the Entertainer and Pam
Grier
[Applause]
and front man for the roots we love him
you can catch him five nights a week on
The Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon last
year he won an Oscar for his documentary
Summers
and this year y'all he might do it again
he is the executive producer of
descendant a new Netflix documentary
that traces the legacy of the last slave
ship to land in the United States
what I know of the story is that it came
down to a bet and Timothy mayor said
yeah we can do this and Captain William
Foster he built the clotilde set sail in
April of 1860 and went into the homie at
the time now benign captured these
individuals came back into Mobile Bay
and was able to
um
release these people sell them to buyers
and and enslave them
Foster was able to take it up the river
and burn it
what was left eventually sunk into the
river
dialing in from New York please welcome
Amir Quest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up plus love say hi to cedrics
how you doing hello guys Tim uh so
question this story was never told in
the history books I'd never heard about
watched the documentary I found it
completely
interesting appalling like all the
things there were so many words to
describe it but it these are the stories
I feel like there's so many like this
that have not been told how do you think
this happens
well you know there is there's a
commonality in terms of why you know
education is important like we're
currently living in a time in which
we're kind of debating is like you know
critical race theory important to teach
at the schools like this story is a
prime example of why that's important
because you know not only did you know
but I was well into my late 40s before I
knew and this is why acknowledging
history is important and why you know
Erasure is real you know we can't know
as a world where we're going unless we
know where we came from so we don't
repeat eat it well before the taping we
asked our audience to watch the film
it's powerful right like I I watched it
last night
and honestly they're so I felt like
watching the documentary literally there
were like almost like four documentaries
in one like you could go off on
different aspects of this and dive
deeper because there's so many things
happening in this community and and just
overall in society so this movie is
personal to you though because you're
not only a producer but also a
descendant right well it's personal to
me because
um back in 2017 I was a guest on the PBS
show Finding Your Roots with skip Gates
and it was there uh for the first time
in my life that I had heard of Benin
that I heard the name Charles and Maggie
Lewis uh that I heard of in Africa town
you know one one percent of African
Americans in this country uh can name
their uh their slave ship could name uh
the country that they came from like 99
of us don't know what part of Africa we
came from that's like one of the largest
continents in the world so you know that
makes you feel complete inside like I
did the show and suddenly I came from
not knowing I had a history to knowing
that I'm literally somebody like I know
where I came from
um so when the story of this film came
up I just wanted to be a part of it just
so that I I can have life completion and
on knowing who my family is but
um yeah if any way that I can Elevate or
bring forth a story
um amplify it I'm I'm with it absolutely
with it yeah so questlove's man-made
Black Thought is also an executive
producer on the film and the movie was
picked up by Barack and Michelle Obama's
production company so Chris why do you
think these stories are so important to
share
um you know I think for me personally uh
again it's it's it's a feeling of
completion you know again like I have
friends who know that they're Italian I
have friends that know that they're from
France or or Switzerland or you know
um and not many black people in the
United States could say like oh my
family came from Ghana or my family came
from you know South Africa or any other
part of of the continent
um and as a result there might be a kind
of nihilistic
um
incompletion that incomplete feeling
that we have as human beings I instantly
know that the second I heard like the
name Benin and you know where I came
from instantly my whole demeanor changed
you know and that's why I I feel as
though this is important because we now
have the tools to to see where we came
from yeah
um so now's I think now is the the first
time in our lives in which we can find
out what our history is that's why it's
important yeah connection is important I
I feel like and also I feel like these
stories are important too because it
really does show you just slaps you in
the face with imbalance opportunity is
not there for people
education to even help their own
Community is not available to people
like it's it's it really does I think
the the documentary does a great job of
depicting imbalance and how true that is
people talk about it but it does a great
job you visually see it happening and
you experience it with the people of
this town the way my mother told me
the mayor a local businessman made a bit
that after slavery was abolished that he
could still bring Africans into the
country and he went and got a bunch of
Africans and
brought us brought them back here
to the mouth of the Mobile River
just let them off the boat and burn the
ship to conceal the crime
welcome back on this Martin Luther King
Jr day I'm here with Cedric the
Entertainer
[Applause]
descendant which Chronicles the katilda
the last slave ship to come to America
it also documents modern-day Africa town
in Mobile Alabama residents there are
said to be the descendants of that ship
and that Legacy was proven true when
they found the clitilda in 2019 it's
executive produced by Amir Quest Lev
Thompson and he's on the line with us
from New York it also features my next
guest like Questlove she's a direct
descendant from the clatilda and she
still lives in the area to this day
please welcome Vida Tunstall y'all
hello
I literally I'm no BS I connected with
you so much in the film I feel like we
have similar thoughts when when you're
talking about things on on you know
Justice and and
how do you fix it where do you go and
and even leaving things open to like we
need help like there's what what do you
do like ideas and I felt like I
connected with you so much on that so to
send it connects the past to the present
so tell us about the challenges facing
your community because like even how it
leaves off the documentary like what it
it leaves off with like it's kind of
like open-ended like things are still
trying to progress so where are you at
right now there are
um organizations and people who've been
at work for all these years like it's
not new that work is being done in
Africa town but there's still a lot of
work to be done it's still true that the
community is surrounded on all sides by
heavy industry there's work being done
to mitigate the negative impact of those
um those plants and all the chemical
um you know the amount of people with
cancer is pain yes yeah and I was just
talking to a friend of mine a few days
ago who used to teach at Mobile County
training school and she said somebody
needs to do some research on this
because the number of children with
neurological disorders and intellectual
disabilities she was like it's got to be
because the soil is toxic the air is
toxic and the water is toxic so today
there's a lot of work being done on the
end with environmental justice or I call
it environmental Injustice that we are
we were just in Washington DC speaking
with people from the EPA about resources
to help Africa town with that this
community was self-sustaining some years
ago until it was incorporated into the
city of mobile so there were
there were businesses there was Health
Care there was everything there but now
it's not there so they addressed that in
the documentary he was like I used to
live here used to live across the street
now it's all changed it's all gone yeah
so now that this film has come out it's
shine Delight over the whole world on
Africa town so what we are hoping now is
that because everybody's paying
attention that we can do something about
these things we are already speaking
with the EPA and federal government on
local government you know we're we're
having to work with our local government
because they're not really addressing
the issues like we need them to so we're
still working on that
we need access to health care there's no
clinic in Africa Town people have
transportation issues so even though
there are needs in the community there
is this it's a proud Community people
are working hard to bring Africa Town
back to the community that it used to be
so flourish like it was yeah I think
that is also what's so important about
and you know thank you question thank
you all these producers that are you're
shining a light you're saying well we've
been doing this for a minute but see
nobody knew like this is important that
people shine a light people that have a
spotlight to take that Spotlight shine
it where it needs to go and really
because there are so many people that
watch that go what can I do what can I
do how can I help you know there are
people watching that are like wait I
know I've worked with you know the EPA
on this maybe I can help here at this
people I think I have to believe always
that there's hope like that that people
want to help and I just think this is
what's so important about films like
this and documentaries about this is
that this is real life this isn't a
movie right this is these are people's
lives you know and and to call it like
what it is to say what it is you know
gentrification to say what it is these
people are encroaching on it they want
everybody to leave they want to keep
their plants there they don't want to
change it that's because it's greed and
power rule the world absolutely and and
you know at the end it's not nothing's
changed people need help like people
need that so that's why I'm so glad that
you're here
um talking to us about it and I'm so
glad that um people watching will get to
maybe have that impact what we reached
out to our friends at myheritage which
lets anyone easily Trace their family
history through their website
myheritage.com they love the work the
African Town Heritage preservation
Foundation is doing for the community so
they're going to donate ten thousand
dollars to help out because they would
touch
and as we mentioned descendant is
released through the Obama's production
company Michelle Obama is encouraging
everyone to share their family history
through photos and stories use the
hashtag descendant challenge
[Music]
[Applause]
guys I'm going home
[Music]